you know I have always gone to you to
help me understand tax policy why have
you now turned your attention to tax
collectors it's almost April fifteenth
and so everybody's paying attention to
the IRS and it's an agency under an
enormous amount of stress so you've got
the general fiscal pressure that
Republicans have put on the budget on
every agency and then some really
specific pressure that's happened in the
past couple of years after the Tea Party
controversy in 2013 and what's happened
is you've got an IRS where everybody is
pretty much demoralized and frustrated
yeah I mean why why does exactly so I'm
reading now from the cover of the
Bloomberg Businessweek story I know you
don't write the cover but it does read
the IRS sucks and what they mean there
is that it sucks to work there what what
exactly is so difficult about being at
the IRS right now look if you go to work
at the IRS you know even in good times
and flush time for the IRS budget that
it's an unpleasant place to work
taxpayers aren't going to like you
necessarily you don't want to always say
where you work when you go to parties
but now it's even worse so the the
budget constraints have really limited
them we talked to employees who you know
they lost a secretary in this office in
Philadelphia that we visited so now
they're all sharing that job employees
are calling their kids because they
can't get tech support from the IRS
they're calling their kids to figure out
how to fix their computers there's is
and and then the Tea Party controversy
to double that because now they're
hearing even more frustration from
taxpayers the lines are out the door and
so it's a particularly rough time to
work there yeah rich I was looking at
the UK equivalent to the IRS the hmrc
and there was a great service saying
twenty two percent of people have
actually said that they want to leave
the hmrc in the next 12 months do you
have similar figures for the IRS I mean
if it's so bad and how many people will
leave people are leaving they expect to
lose another three to four thousand
employees this year just from retirement
one of the things they've talked about
is that the workforce is really aging so
lots of people are eligible for
retirement and we talked to a number of
people in the story you said gosh i'm
eligible it's time to just go and so the
IRS is in a real bind they've been in a
hiring freeze off and on for
for years now and they want to attract
younger workers they they want to bring
people in and help them learn from the
older workers but the older workers are
going to be leaving faster than they can
bring people in Rachel try to be as a
political as I can when I ask this
question but when the IRS is underfunded
does it cost us anything yes it
absolutely does but the IRS says is look
if you give us more money for
enforcement they'll will produce two to
four to seven dollars in additional
money for the government now what
Republicans say is look the IRS is not
particularly efficient we can point to
employee time spent on union work it's a
bonus is paid to people who haven't paid
their taxes rehiring employees who
haven't paid their taxes and so what
Republicans say is look iris you've got
to just clean up your act even more than
what you've done before we'll give you
some more money rich let me just jump in
with a real quick question you know what
are the odds that this will get fixed
this year because we'll have fundamental
tax reform tax reform right we go right
under your lavender has answered the
question and now we have to leave it
there